PROFESSOR: So now we start on
another topic in graph theory,
namely the topic
of simple graphs.
So last week we were talking
about directed graphs
where the arrows have
a beginning and an end,
as shown here.
But simple graphs are simpler.
The edges don't have direction.
They just correspond to a mutual
connection, which is symmetric.
So there's a picture
of a simple graph,
and the edges are shown
without an arrowhead.
A special thing
about directed graphs
is that it's possible
to have an arrow going
in each direction
between two vertices.
But when we have
undirected edges like this,
that doesn't happen.
So there's only one
edge between a pair
of vertices in a simple graph.
In addition, a
directed graph might
have a self loop, an edge
that starts and begins
at the-- starts and
ends at the same vertex.
And those are also
disallowed in simple graphs.
Now, you could
allow those things.
There's a thing
called multi-graphs
where there are multiple
edges between vertices.
And there could also be self
loops, but we don't need those.
Let's not complicate matters.
We're talking about
simple graphs.
OK, so the formal
definition of a simple graph
is that it's an object G
that has a bunch of parts.
Namely it has a nonempty
set, v of vertices,
just like directed graphs.
And it has a set E of
edges, but the edges now
are somewhat different since
they don't have beginnings
and ends.
An edge just has two
endpoints that are in V,
and we don't distinguish
the endpoints.
So let's just draw a picture.
Here's a case where there are
six vertices V shown in blue,
and there are these undirected
edges shown in green.
In this case I see
seven edges in E.
There is an example of an edge
that goes between two vertices
that I've highlighted
in yellow and red.
And we've made that
particular edge dark green.
An edge like that can
formally be represented
as just the set of its end
points, a set of two things,
red and yellow.
In text, we'll often indicate
it as the two vertices connected
by a horizontal bar.
But you have to remember
that the order in which
the red and the
yellow occur don't
matter, because it's
really a set consisting
of red and yellow.
When two vertices are
connected by an edge,
they are said to be adjacent.
And the edge is
said to be incident
to its end points, just a little
vocabulary that we use here.
A basic concept in
graph theory, which
is what we're going
to make a little bit
of in this video segment, is the
idea of the degree of a vertex.
The degree of a vertex is simply
the number of incident edges,
the number of edges,
that touch it,
the number of edges for
which its an end point.
So let's look at the red vertex.
There are two edges
incident to the red vertex,
so its degree is 2.
OK, let's look at
the yellow vertex.
Here there are four edges
incident to the yellow vertex,
so its degree is 4.
No surprises yet.
So let's examine some
properties of vertex degrees
that are motivated
by a simple example.
Suppose I asked
the question, is it
possible to have a graph with
vertex degrees of 2, 2, and 1.
So implicitly it's
a 3 vertex graph.
And one vertex has degree
2, another has degree 2,
and one has degree 1.
Well let's see
what it looks like.
If I'm going to have
a vertex of degree 1,
then I know what it looks like.
There's the vertex.
It's got one edge out of it.
It's going to some other vertex.
Now this other vertex
must have degree 2,
so it's connected
to something else.
And the something else must be
another vertex with degree 2,
because those are the only
possible spectrum of degrees,
1, 2, and 2.
And that means
that this last guy
has to have an edge out of
it, because it's degree 2.
And it can't go back to
2, because there's already
an edge between these two.
And it can't go back to 1,
because that has degree 1.
So we're stuck.
And by this ad hoc
reasoning we figured out
that there can't be a degree
3 graph with this spectrum
of degrees 2, 2, 1.
It's impossible.
Well, we could have
reasoned more generally.
And there's a very elementary
property of degrees
that we're going to actually
make something of in a minute.
And it's called the
handshaking lemma.
It says that the
sum of the degrees
summed over all the
vertices is equal to twice
the number of edges.
There it is written
as a formula,
twice the number of edges.
So that's the
cardinality symbol.
Absolute value of a set
means the size of the set.
E here is finite.
Twice the number of
edges is equal to the sum
over all the vertices of
the degree of the vertices.
Why is that true?
Well, if you think about
it, in the sum on the right,
every edge is counted
twice, once for each vertex
that it's the end of.
So we're really just
count-- and this
is a way of summing up
over all of the vertices
in which each vertex
gets numerated twice.
So the sum is twice
the number of vertices.
And the proof is trivial, but
let's make something of this.
You might wonder why it's
called the handshaking lemma.
That will emerge
in some problems
that we're going to have you do.
But let's go on and apply
the handshaking lemma
in an interesting way.
And by the way, of course,
since 2 plus 2 plus 1 is odd,
we could have without that
ad hoc analysis figured out
that the sum of the
degrees can't be odd,
because it's twice something.
All right, so here's
the applications
designed to get your attention.
It is an application
of graph theory to sex.
And we ask the question, are
men more promiscuous than women?
And there have been
repeated studies
that are cited in the notes that
show again and again that when
they survey collections
of men and women
and ask them how many
sexual partners they have,
it's consistently the case that
the men are assessed to have
30% more, 75% more,
sometimes 2 and 1/2 times,
3 times as many
partners as the women.
And there's got to be
something wacky about this.
We're going to come up with
a very elementary graph
theoretic argument that says
that this is complete nonsense.
By the way, the most recent
study that we could find
was one that's mentioned
in the notes in 2007
by the US Department of Health.
And the statistician
who collected the data
knew that the results
were impossible.
But her job was to
report the data, not
to explain it or interpret it.
And the men reported 30%
more partners than the women.
And we're going to show
that somebody is lying.
Here's how we're going to do it.
We're going to model the
relationships between men
and women by having a graph
that comes in two parts.
It's going to be called a
so-called bipartite graph.
So there's going to be
one set of vertices called
M and another set of
vertices called F. M for men
and f for women, or females.
And we're going to have edges
going between men and women,
between M's and F's, precisely
when they have been involved
in a sexual liaison.
So looking back at this graph,
this edge from that blue M
to that orange F indicates
that they had a sexual liaison.
They were partners.
OK, so this is a
simple graph structure
that we can use to
represent who got together
with whom in any given
population of men and women.
Now, if you think
about the same argument
that we use for handshaking, if
you sum the degrees of the men,
you're counting each
edge exactly once.
And so the sum of the
degrees of the men
is equal to the number
of edges in this graph.
And likewise, if you
sum over the females,
you're counting each edge once.
And so the sum of
the female degrees
is also equal to
the number of edges.
In particular, the sum over
the degrees of the males
is equal to the sum over
the degrees of the females.
Because every time
there's a liaison,
it involves one
male, one female.
All right, now let's
just do a little bit
of elementary arithmetic.
I'm going to divide both
sides of this equality
by the size of the
male population,
by the number of men.
And if I do that,
I get this formula.
The left hand side
is the number of-- is
the sum of the degrees of men
divided by the size of the M
population.
And here I'm doing
a little trick.
Notice that the F's cancel out.
But I've expressed some of
the female degrees divided
by M as the sum of the female
degrees divided by F times
this factor F over M, which is
the ratio of the populations
of women to men.
Now the reason I'm doing
this is that if you
look at this thing
on the left, this is
the average degree of the men.
This is the sum of
all the degrees of men
divided by the number of men.
So it's the average number
of partners that men have.
And likewise, now you
can recognize over here
that I've got the average
number of partners
that each woman has.
And what we've just
figured out then
is that there's a
fixed relationship
between the average
number of partners of men,
the average degree
of the M vertices
and the average degree
of the F vertices.
And these two average
degree, these average numbers
of partners, is simply
related by the ratio
of the populations.
The men degree is
the female population
divided by the M population
times the average degree
of the females.
Now, what this tells us
is that these wild figures
of twice as many, and
30% more, and so on
are completely absurd.
Because we know a lot
about the ratio of females
to males in the population.
As a matter of fact,
in the US overall
there are slightly
more women than men.
There is 1.035 women for each
man in the US population.
And that tells us then
that if you surveyed
the population of all the
men and women in the country,
you would discover that the men
looked 3 and 1/2 percent more--
had 3 and 1/2 percent more
partners than women per man.
But this has nothing to do with
their behavior, or promiscuity,
or lack of it.
It's simply a reflection of
the ratio of the populations.
Which gets us to
the question of,
where do these crazy
numbers come from?
And the answer seems to
be that people are lying.
One explanation would
be that men exaggerate
their number of partners,
and women understate
their number of partners.
But the truth is
that nobody knows
exactly why we get these
consistently false numbers.
But we do get them consistently
in one survey after another.
You will no longer be
fooled by such nonsense.